hi I'm patty Kim we're making a cup of
java to cooking the perfect meal the
kitchen is the heart of the house but
what you might not realize is that it's
also the place where you use the most
energy let's take a look if you'd like
to cut back on how much energy and water
you use and save on your utility bills
the first thing you can do is take a
closer look at how you actually use your
appliances you might also want to think
about switching out to newer more
efficient appliances the most
power-hungry appliance in the kitchen is
by far the refrigerator these units tend
to last a long time and if it's over 10
years old it could be using sixty
percent more energy than a newer model
these side by side refrigerators can
sometimes use up to twenty percent more
power than the freezer top kind and I
can make a big difference for maximum
efficiency set the freezer temperature
20 degrees and the fridge to 40 degrees
vacuuming the coils will also help keep
your fridge running in tip-top shape now
if you spend a lot of time in the
kitchen cooking or baking for the family
I'm trying to get some brownies going
here it's amazing how something as
simple as using your stove efficiently
can actually help save you energy on the
stovetop something as simple as matching
pots and pans to the right size heating
element makes a big difference if you're
baking check whether preheating is
essential also you might want to think
about doubling up and cooking a couple
of dishes at the same time but you gotta
resist peeking opening the door can drop
the oven temperature as much as 50
degrees while reheating leftovers you
can save energy by using your toaster
oven instead of the oven to cook small
portions better yet use the microwave it
draws eighty-five percent less energy
than a conventional cooktop to save
resources during cleanup let your
kitchen do the work washing dishes in
the sink can end up using fifty percent
more water than the dishwasher so you
can cut down on all that wasted energy
by using your dishwasher but of course
the key is to only run it on full loads
and I want to turn off the dry cycle and
just let them air dry newer
energy-efficient dishwashers can save
you thirteen percent on energy and a
whopping 1200 gallons of water a year
over an older model but the best way by
far to make sure you're saving as much
energy in the kitchen as possible is by
upgrading investing in newer and more
efficient appliances when shopping for a
new refrigerator or other appliance look
for the Energy Star label this label
means the appliance surpasses minimum
government standards and is about twenty
percent more efficient than conventional
models you can compare appliance models
by looking at the energy
label it lists the yearly power
consumption and operating costs stoves
don't carry energy ratings but we still
have some things to look for if you're
set on purchasing a gas stove make sure
it has an electronic ignition pilot
flames waste gas also make sure the
stove receives adequate ventilation if
you're purchasing an electric range
check out induction cooktops they're
nearly fifty percent more efficient than
conventional gas and electric cooktops
they're sleek surfaces induce heat into
the steel cookware leaving the stovetop
cool ceramic glass cook tops are also a
great improvement over standard coil
cooktops even if you don't buy new
appliances small changes can go a long
way look at it this way in the long run
you'll be saving energy the environment
and some money it'll be worth it I'm
patty Kim we'll see you next time